bonsoir le théâtre la comédie le cinéma
sont en deuil l'un des plus grands
autres réacteurs français jean poiret
est mort ce matin à l'âge de 65 ans dans
une carrière pleine d'humour au théâtre
on distinguera évidemment la fameuse
cage aux folles qu'il avait écrite et
interprétée sur scène avec son complice
michel serrault hommage à un surdoué du
spectacle signé dominique poncet
plus on avance plus c'est difficile
parce que plus on avance plus on pense
avoir de métier et comme on se dit avoir
du métier ça n'est pas bon plus c'est
difficile d'échapper à ce métier qui
stipulait que vous souhaitiez il n'y
aura jamais échappé s'il fallait résumer
sa vie d'une formule on pourrait dire
jean poiret ou 40 ans d'extrême
loufoquerie et de sublimes bouffonnerie
car il n'aura jamais arrêté jean poiret
depuis ses débuts en 1952 ou au cabaret
chez gilles avec son complice michel 0
il fit s'étouffer de rire des salles
entières jusqu'à sans rancune je voyais
actuellement au théâtre du palais royal
et dont il avait signé l'adaptation par
le mauvais avec au moins deux passions
faire l'acteur et écrire écrire pour le
théâtre bien sûr
et s'il ne fallait en citer que deux de
ses pièces on rappellerait joyeuses
pâques et bien sûr l'inénarrable cage
aux folles
si je n'écris pas aimer t-il à dire je
suis en manque un brin l'honneur dix
fois moins je n'aurais pas su naître
qu'acteur je trouve que je
je vais faire haïr par mes autres
camarades qui me son capteur et je
trouve que c'est pas tout à fait
totalement une position une position
d'homme c'est un peu une présentation
une position de d'articles dans une
vitrine qui fasse secteur où l'auteur
jean poiret contrairement aux apparences
ne fut jamais un frivole son métier il
exerça son fils elle ni trucage ni
automatisme et c'est sans doute pour
cela que le public l'aimé de l'ajout de
la rive
il faut se donner se donner à fond dans
un personnage je crois qu'il faut être
totalement sincère et plus on joue des
choses folles plus il faut être sincère
c'est moi c'est pour moi c'est la
netteté
si on vient faire du bureau et si on
vient dire des répliques en mettant le
choix 20h30 le pilotage automatique
ça m'intéresse plus et moi je m'arrête
marceline à moins de l'allier ce qui est
presque sûr c'est que toute sa vie il se
sera fuient car son obsession de fait
rire aura été un moyen d'oublier
n'oubliez l'angoissent l'angoissent du
bide angoisses du vide et récemment l'
angoisse de vieillir
commence à me proposer les grands pères
mais alors là j'ai là je refuse
systématiquement jeudi jeudi belmondo ne
joue pas les grands-pères belmondo n'a
pas d'âge
et je n'aurai pas d'âme je persiste et
je signe l'émotion et douleur dans
toutes les réactions cet après midi
voici celle de son complice de toujours
le comédien michel serrault avec qui il
avait formé un duo inséparable dans les
années 50 jusqu'à l'apothéose de la cage
aux folles donc en 1973 réactions
recueillies par clément weill raynal et
par patrick milliards
alors je suis je suis comme tout le
monde sait cg énormément de chagrin
évidemment et comme tout le monde je
suis pas autrement que les autres
aujourd'hui je comprends pas ce qui
arrive je quand je pense à nous deux je
pense qu'on a vécu ensemble les
meilleures années de notre vie et je
prouve chevaux aux millions millions de
gens qui ont vu poiret serrault dans la
cage aux folles je pense à toute notre
carrière au au cabaret cette complicité
extraordinaire qui était doublée si vous
voulez du d'amitié je pense qu'on peut
dire parfaite cette étude de whittier de
de respect et l'amitié de pudeur chacun
avec de nature au cinéma jean poiret
avait participé à plus de trente longs
métrages sur la direction de françois
truffaut de claude chabrol ou encore de
jean pierre mocky avec lequel il avait
joué notamment dans le miraculé
monsieur fox
qu'est ce que ce monsieur fox ils ont
répété tout fout de ma gueule
moi je me présente gentiment hein alors
atténué au thème était plus court à
petits pas à un accident com - un homme
a tiré dessus qu est ce qu un test
mais c'est une photo du pape est alors
et voyous tout en tirer des cambistes et
à stocker jusqu à une bavure et à
toucher l'assurance et par mois rien du
tout au rien du tout merci monsieur je
cherche un wagon 38 monsieur étant
malade aussi lit marche pays par le port
roche parle mais je marche pas et j'ai
appelé jean poiret est un personnage
étonnant humour grinçant un
pince-sans-rire corrosif que ce soit la
ville d'ailleurs comme à la scène tout à
fait d'ailleurs vous savez il y avait
pour habitude de dire qu'en définitive
il n'avait pas une goutte de sang
anglais mais qui l'aimé beaucoup ça chez
les anglais c'est humeau britannique un
peu à froid
et si vous voulez quand il parle puisque
nous avons fait son divan il parlait des
débuts de sa carrière et il disait qu'en
définitive il avait vu de spectacle de
la mort enfants parce que la maison des
parents donnaient rue de la tombe
issoire sur un cimetière et près d'une
église et qu'à force de voir ses rideaux
là et bien il a opté pour la gaieté et
il s'est dit que la vie ça doit être le
riz avec ses sacs on devait apporter aux
gens et je crois aussi que ce qui
m'attriste et c'est qu'il avait dit au
fond il faudrait vivre 70 ans
d'expérience c'est un brouillon et après
ça prend un gros match demain à jean
poiret en rediffusant l'émission le
divan ou la vie reçue en 1986 89 sacré à
peine trois ans paraît donc qui est mort
ce matin à l'âge de 65 ans à l'étranger
l'état d'urgence a été déclaré dans la
région des résines canal est de la
turquie
la ville a été en partie détruite hier
par un violent séisme qui aurait fait
plus d'un millier de morts les travaux
de sauvetage reste difficile l'an à
s'organiser en raison de l'étendue des
dégâts
commentaire de catherine matausch
trente secondes d'horreur à la tombée de
la nuit hier soir des milliers de turcs
sont alors rassemblés pour rompre le
jeûne du ramadan pendant 30 secondes le
centre d'ait rzine carne cette ville 275
mille habitants va littéralement se
couche et engloutissant dans les
décombres des centaines de personnes
vingt-quatre heures après le séisme la
confusion reste grande
les secours ont toujours beaucoup de mal
à s'organiser des scènes de panique et
classe le plus souvent lors de la
distribution de vivres et de couvertures
pour accélérer les secours
l'état d'urgence a été décrété il est
encore impossible de connaître le nombre
des victimes neil morts estiment les
autorités plutôt 4000 affirme en fin de
journée la fédération internationale de
la croix rouge à 7h militaire et
bénévoles recherchent toujours des
survivants
la population s'apprête à passer une
deuxième nuit dehors par peur de
nouvelles secousses dans une ville
toujours privée d'eau et d'électricité
certains pleurent et se souviennent
située sur une faille
erin kahn avait été détruite par un
tremblement de terre il y à 50 ans ici
même trente mille personnes avaient été
tuées ce soir le gouverneur jean kahn
dénoncent le non-respect des règles
d'urbanisme dans une région à haut
risque
la france a annoncé ce soir l'envoi en
turquie de deux unités spécialisées de
la sécurité civile ces deux unités
représentent environ 80 personnes avec
200 tonnes de matériel violant ainsi
dans la nuit dernière à nouméa en
nouvelle calédonie des jeunes gens de la
banlieue de la ville ont incendié le
plus grand centre commercial de la
capitale avant d'être rejoints par
quelques centaines de manifestants
l'alcool le désoeuvrement semble être à
l'origine de ces incidents qui ont pris
naissance dans une altercation avec le
portier d'une boîte de nuit
commentaire de fernand tavarès crs et
gardes mobiles kadri aujourd'hui les
alentours et le centre de nouméa la nuit
dernière furieux d'avoir été éconduit à
l'entrée d'un night club de jeunes
mélanésiens ont pillé et incendié le
grand complexe commercial de la capitale
calédonienne
véritable symbole de la réussite des
européens installés sur ce territoire du
pacifique sud
traumatisée par les événements qui ont
mis à feu et à sang l'archipel en 1984 à
85 ou encore parler massacre d'ouvéa
kanaks et caldoches avait tout de même
réussi à entamer sur la base des accords
de matignon
un processus de réconciliation à long
terme même si les protestations
spontanées et musclée de quelques 500
commerçants auprès du haut commissaire
de la république ont été prises en
compte
l'avertissement lancé par le fln 15
quelques heures avant ces incidents
trouble le fragile équilibre retrouvé
de plus en plus de jeunes kanaks
viennent comme à l'île de la réunion
grossir le rang des chômeurs et il se
sent toujours exclu le ministre des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
louis le pensec a promis ir même sur le
caillou que les contrats de ville en
cours de préparation apporterait une
réponse aux problèmes sociaux de
nouvelle calédonie et des mesures
exceptionnelles de sécurité seront
prises dès ce soir à nouméa pour éviter
tout débordement
politique les chantiers navals de la
ciotat nouvel enjeu électoral dans la
région provence alpes côte d'azur après
avoir rencontré pierre bérégovoy la cgt
estime qu'elle a marqué un point et elle
a d'ailleurs réaffirmé sa détermination
aujourd'hui à bernard tapie en visite
sur le chantier lequel s'est défendu de
toute intervention à caractère électoral
dans cette affaire reportage à la ciotat
de jérôme cathala et de marque tout
retour à la ciotat en 1989
bernard tapie l'industriel avait tenté
de monter un projet de reconversion du
chantier naval
aujourd'hui c'est le candidat tapie qui
revient dans sa besace l'accord verbal
de pierre bérégovoy pour la reprise de
l'activité des chantiers
une bonne surprise pour ceux qui depuis
trois ans et demi occupent les lieux les
une surprise qui à quelques jours des
élections régionales incite à la
prudence et le leader de la cgt de la
ciotat attend maintenant des actes de la
part du gouvernement
même prudence d'ailleurs du côté de
bernard tapie qui ne veut pas paraître
dans cette affaire que comme un modeste
intermédiaire caire n'était pas
compliqué elle était simple
est-ce que vous pouvez nous aider à
rencontrer bérégovoy c'était pas très
compliqué comme boulot rhin pour la
réponse j'ai essayé ils se rencontrent
et pierre bérégovoy décide d'épouser
leur thèse qu'est-ce que j'y peux
bref bernard tapie ne souhaite pas
s'engager personnellement plus avant
c'est que l'enjeu est d'importance si la
situation se débloque dans la semaine
qui vient
cela sera mis à son crédit mais il ne
veut pas prêter le flanc aux accusations
de coup de pub électorale qui sont
portées contre lui qu'on ne leur laisse
pas un espoir de rêve qui se traduira
par une plus grande amertume épurant rue
de plus grande hostilité
je trouve que monsieur vérillaud voix et
monsieur tapie ont eu tort de rouvrir ou
de tenter de réouvrir un dossier qui
malheureusement est fermé ou s'il
s'agissait d'une manoeuvre électorale de
dernière minute en chemin ça ne serait
pas digne d'un ministre et du
gouvernement de la france et je crois
qu'ici on s'en souviendraient pendant
longtemps car ici à la ciotat
même si tout le monde est conscient des
échéances électorales
chacun veut se raccrocher à ce dernier
espoir légère hausse de popularité de
françois mitterrand selon le baromètre
mensuel ifop journal du dimanche le
président la république enregistre 26 %
d'opinions favorables contre 24 en
février 59 % se déclarent mécontents
contre 63 en février la nouvelle baisse
en revanche du premier ministre edith
cresson recueille 19 % d'opinions
favorables contre 21 pour cent le mois
dernier
59% d'opinions défavorables contre 57
pour cent au mois de février à
l'étranger israël accusé d'avoir
illégalement revendu de la technologie
militaire américaine à d'autres pays
plusieurs journaux publient ce matin les
résultats d'une enquête des services de
renseignement qui fait état de
transferts d'armes vers la chine
l'afrique du sud ou encore le chili
commentaires de joël françois du mans
scandale à washington où une enquête
vient d'être ouverte pour déterminer si
israël a ou non livré illégalement un
missile patriot et la chine communiste
les révélations du times reprise par le
post et le wall street journal citant
des sources proches des services secrets
ne sont toujours pas démentie côté
américain
bien au contraire le département d'état
est accusée de laxisme un inspecteur
général vient donc d'être chargée de
faire toute la lumière d'ici la fin du
mois sur les exploitations illicites de
haute technologie étaient américaines
par israël à des pays tiers
richard clarke le voici l'homme par qui
le scandale souhaite arriver et son
secrétaire d'état aux affaires politico
militaires
selon ces grands quotidiens américains
les tabourets exporter des missiles
antichars plus grave encore des missiles
air air à tête chercheuse avait été
vendu à la chine ainsi que divers
systèmes de brouillage et autres radars
si ces accusations se trouvait confirmée
par l'enquêté ouverte à washington
les relations entre israël et les états
unis pourraient s'en trouver très
gravement affectées côté chinois israël
est en tout cas le démenti se vend en
tout cas formel je suis totalement faux
il n'y a pas la moindre parcelle de
vérité dans ses allégations israël n'a
pas vendu à qui que ce soit les
technologies du patriote vous et aux
faux donc on devrait être fixé bientôt
en tout cas les américains ne pardonne
pas aux israéliens d'avoir vendu les
systèmes d'armes sophistiquées à
l'afrique du sud au chili à la thaïlande
au venezuela et à l'ethiopie les sports
maintenant cyclisme le jeune français
stéphane heulot a remporté détaché
aujourd'hui la septième étape de paris
nice entre toulon et mandelieu à 24
heures de l'arrivée
jean françois bernard conserve le
maillot blanc de leader avec cette toute
petite seconde d'avancé sur l'espagnol
miguel indurain didier andré garcia
pardon sur place par eni cyclisme
à la petit problème sur le cyclisme
paris nice je vais laisser le recalé en
régie je voudrais vous proposer d'abord
toujours en sport un résultat de
football vous dire que pour le compte
des seizièmes de finale de la coupe de
france ce soir après prolongations c'est
finalement quand qui a éliminé lens sur
le score de 5 buts à 4 les deux équipes
étaient à égalité à la fin du temps
réglementaire 3 but partout vous dire
aussi que le français fabrice guy déjà
champion olympique de la spécialité a
officiellement remporté aujourd'hui en
norvège
la coupe du monde de combiné nordique
c'est la première fois qu'un français
remporte la coupe du monde dans une
discipline nordique fabrice qui je vous
le rappelle mais être nécessaire est âgé
de 23 ans
et puis retour maintenant donc sur le
cyclisme pour vous dire que stéphane
heulot a donc enlevé des tâches et la 7e
étape de paris-nice l'étape entre toulon
et mandelieu et que jean-françois
bernard conserve son maillot blanc de
leader à 24 heures de l'arrivée on
retrouve sur place andré garcia cette
fois ça marche
le trio magique bernard hild aura une
roaming heures avait confirmé son
emprise sur le 42e paris-nice au sommet
du mont faron
qu'importe la course fut splendide car
entre toulon et mandelieu un groupe de
hardy attaquant s'est détaché dès les
premiers kilomètres
parmi ceux-ci quelques habitués des cous
audacieux comme jan lammers l'équipier
de lemon chez z
le belge pieter de clerck où son
compatriote jerry commnce de hollandais
encore michel zanoni et édiles sur eure
mais surtout surtout un jeune néo
professionnel français stéphane heulot
déjà vainqueur d'une étape de l'étoile
de bessèges cet espoir de 21 ans dénote
dans la morosité du cyclisme français
il n'a aucun complexe il adore bousculer
les traditions et en particulier les
valeurs établies
bref il a tout pour devenir un beau
champion avec l'intelligence de course
en plus ainsi sur les pentes du tanneron
alors que jan lammers avait préféré
faire exploser le groupe des attaquants
très tôt c'est au train que stéphane
heulot est revenu en compagnie des dix
joueurs
le peloton battue était à 5 minutes
il restait encore à escalader le
grand-duc cette fois stéphane heulot a
pu prendre la course à son compte à
l'arrivée stéphane où l'on remporte sa
deuxième victoire de la saison la plus
belle bien sûr mais c'est toujours avec
le maillot blanc que jean-françois
bernard 9e à mandelieu prendra le départ
de l'étape mandelieu nice avant
d'affronter le col d'eze dimanche après
midi
à suivre demain après midi en direct sur
fr3 les rapports rapidement du tiercé
quarté quinté disputé aujourd'hui à un
gain de 8-3 rapporte 4440 francs dans
l'ordre le quarté + en rajoutant le 5 un
peu plus de 31000 feront toujours dans
l'ordre
enfin le quinté plus en rajoutant las de
8 3 5 m 269 1000es 68 francs dans un
instant météo complète de michel touré
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
soir 3 à 22h50
je vous souhaite d'ici là un très très
bon début de soirée merci